you're saying trump's a [ __ ] i
completely he's a coward
oh he's a bully all bullies are cowards
i don't disagree on the on the bully
side but i don't know i don't know about
the the coward side he's an absolute
coward let me ask you this
did you like the fact that donald trump
lied about the 2020 election
refused to concede
refused to participate in the peaceful
transfer of power
and then led to what happened on january
6. so let me tell you how i'm wired you
got to know how i'm wired okay
when the russia investigation started on
him this is how i'm wired i don't know
if they're right that's dirty i'm
talking 20 20. but i'm going to explain
to you how i'm wired
so when they said he's doing this he's
doing that he's doing this i said
if this is true dude this ain't gonna be
a good look and republicans are gonna
lose the vote for 20 years this could be
a goldwater type of a thing and could
get very very ugly for the republican
party
okay cool so 2020 election
um argo came out how long ago 30 years
after argo happened which was when
1978-79 when did the movie come on cia
has a basic 30-year rule or whatever the
timeline is they got a 20 or 30 year
rule right
30 years later we really found out what
happened at argo okay so the election
what happened
yeah i think we're really going to find
out what happened in 2020 election in
2015. so do you don't necessarily
believe biden won fair and square no i
don't believe i don't believe either one
of them because i'm not on the inside so
for me to give you a hundred percent
answer
i can't give 100 answers and things i'm
not involved in i can give you 100
answers and things i'm involved in i'm
not in the white house okay yeah so you
don't know if the 2020 election was
legit
do you like the fact that trump says it
was stolen
yes or no i think okay so let me you
ever lost publicly
yes okay how much does it suck it sucks
it sucks okay all right so like you've
been saying the last six years you've
been losing it sucks right whatever
since 2018 four years your life all this
other stuff it sucks it's humiliating
nobody likes it none of us like it i
don't like it you don't like it trump
doesn't like you nobody but what do real
men do hang on one second hang on one
second i'm gonna give you my answer so
uh hillary loses 16. what does she say
oh it was it was russia
patrick you're not being truthful with
your audience i'm going to give you my
answer but you're not that's not true
but that is true no the first thing she
did no it's not the first thing she did
on the view and everywhere else
i love you brother but that's not right
the first you're saying she never said
that
the morning after the 2016 election the
first [ __ ] thing hillary clinton did
was go on national television and
concede that's why congratulations
and offering a hell of a work with two
different questions these are two
different questions you just said that
was the first thing hillary clinton
these are two different questions let me
give you i'll give you the answer on
both of them number one
the moment hillary lost still having fun
the moment hillary lost hillary said
there was the bots that helped trump get
elected you can't deny that did she
concede that night with the phone call
let me tell you no she didn't paul d
podesta was in front of every microphone
and she had not the phone call
she went on national television the
morning after the election brother no
i'll tell you no that's not no in front
of you country oh my gosh you're not
gonna let me finish in this part go
ahead i i'll tell you one part okay so
in regards to russia she said that
constantly four
years now what i didn't like about what
trump did here's what i didn't like
about what trump did
the next president inauguration
whether they cheated or not what are you
doing not being there
i don't like that
if if if a country has traditions
traditions are above you you know what i
like about what michael jordan said one
time about lebron james here's what
michael jordan said about lebron james
lebron james made a comment he says i
believe there's one jersey in the nba
that needs to be retired forever the
number 23.
they asked my you're from illinois so
you know the story they asked michael
jordan what do you think about this you
know what he said he says no one man is
bigger than the nba
i think trump thought he's bigger than
america i don't think he is i don't
think anybody is so
maybe that's your way of saying
that you're disappointed that trump
didn't put the country's interests
before his own the tradition
forget about the trinity
forget about the jerusalems for a minute
pat
put that what's best for the country is
even if you got questions about the the
election there was an election biden was
declared the winner i don't like it i'm
[ __ ] pissed off it was stolen from me
but america comes first our democracy
comes first it sucks biden won i'll help
him with the transition i'll show up at
his inauguration so the american people
can see that this thing still kind of
works you're disappointed that trump
didn't do that one million percent thank
you one on one this one
look but and by the way i've been saying
this for a
long time yeah there's i don't think
there's a debate on this yeah one
million percent i i i i i joe didn't
know that he wanted to hear that yeah
but what i'm saying
i'm living in america
i'm i'm i'm i'm nothing in america
there's two ways i view myself one
i'm one person you're just one person
you're just one but you can't really
make an impact i know for a fact i can
make an impact but i also think from the
other center bipolar relation i'm just
if i die tomorrow world's going to
continue you know steve job was a
massive guy he died we moved on when you
and i die we're going to move on this
has been said a lot of different
scriptures a lot of good books and you
can read about it as much of an
important person we think we're going to
move on and the world's going to move on
with us so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]